it is going to be a hot weekend let's
get to your forecast everybody hot in
the satay and we're going to have lots
of visitors in town
so if you're going to stay close to the
strip if you're entertaining friends and
family
just prepare everybody for the heat have
lots of water around take it with you
wherever you're going
73 up at kyle canyon today with some
light southerly breezes
upper 60s up at lee canyon pushing close
to 70 degrees by monday
we're going to get more clouds around
tomorrow as a system does push into
southern california
it'll probably bring some showers to the
sierras but i don't think we're going to
get
showers we'll just have some cumulus
clouds around
lots of 70s around the valley this
morning we haven't cooled off too much
from yesterday's 96
officially 67 at nella 68 at aliante
so we're looking to be a little bit
hotter today up to 99
93 is the average so we're definitely
above normal
at least we're not the record 109 we
don't want to be that hot yet but i have
a lot of triple digits coming next week
for june sunset by the way 7 50 so the
day is naturally getting longer we have
a few more weeks until we officially
start summer but this weekend's always
the unofficial start
to summer there is a system up north
that will bring a few showers way up
north
for us that system forming off the
southern california coast as i say
will bring in a few clouds tomorrow big
thunderstorms in the southern plains
again today if you're traveling
dallas to memphis had been rocking and
rolling with thunderstorms overnight
so lots of good sunshine oh here are
those storms i did have them here for
you
you can see that some of them have been
weakening but there has been a lot of
rain
so you might have some delays if you are
flying all right 99 for the valley today
we'll take a little dip in temps
tomorrow with the clouds around
and maybe some breezes along with those
clouds as well up to about 15 or 20
miles an hour
back to hot sunshine sunday and our
first triple digit day
could come as soon as memorial day on
monday boulder city is
having in-person events for memorial day
observances they're going to be placing
flags
the veterans memorial cemetery tomorrow
morning and then they will have an
official
service at 1 pm on monday and then the
vets
motorcycle club the legacy club they'll
be riding across hoover dam
on sunday so all those wonderful things
that
we love to see the traditions uh to
honor our fallen
heroes and our service people will be
happening over the weekend with coveted
restrictions and safety protocols
next week here comes the heat 104 105.
oh everybody be safe in the heat here
comes summertime nate